this is the biggest image i've ever
taken in this episode i attempt to turn
a four-ton truck into a camper
and in the process i lose a bit of my
sanity all kinds of mind games here how
important is this picture
possibly
one of the gnarliest things i've done
hey i'm dan mace i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
i wrote down this question six years ago
and in all honesty i can't remember why
or how i came up with the idea but i
like it and i found a use for it now and
that use is my wall
[Music]
i hate this wall it's a clinically white
stain in the middle of a seemingly
vibrant studio i need to do something
about it i must do something about it i
need to fill it with something but what
i could paint it but that would be an
uncreative solution to a big problem
this wall will be here forever i stared
at every time i opened the roller door i
need to fill it with a memoir a reminder
a symbol of something great an image
after some contemplating and staring out
the window i saw the corner of table
mountain the wonder of cape town south
africa the icon that means home to me
i need to capture this in a picture but
not any picture the picture
so i rented this truck i called around
my strong friend bravo who can also
drive a truck loaded in the heaviest
table i could find bolt a wall with a
door that fits perfectly at the back of
the truck drilled a hole in the center
bought this miniature lens made out of
plastic online i got my friend mike to
make me an aperture ring and a shutter
card to attach to the back of the
plastic lens i stuck this vinyl print to
the front of the wall for aesthetic
reasons only i then cut around the door
and the hole i stacked the lens and the
aperture ring into the hole i bought a
bunch of resin based photo paper some
fixer and developer four basins gloves
nylon string pegs tongs three red safety
lights that i'll power with this battery
and one large white board
[Music]
but why the truck to get the size of the
image needed the truck was the only
portable sized container that would work
and it makes framing a lot easier to
have this gigantic camera on wheels how
it works is pretty complex but here's an
easy to understand animation made
entirely for you poking a small hole in
a light sealed box allows light rays to
enter which project an upside down and
flipped image of whatever it's pointed
at onto the interior of the box the
image gets inverted because light
travels in straight lines light from the
ground will continue through the hole
and land onto the top of the box while
light from the sky hits the bottom
flipping the image both vertically and
horizontally our eyes work the same way
but our brains normalize this so that we
can function properly the ability to
distinguish waves of light is referred
to as sharpness to achieve a sharper
image we place a lens in the front of
the hole known as the aperture lenses
are made out of transparent material
like postfix or glass that are shaped to
bend and focus rays of light resulting
in brighter and sharper images to
capture the projected image we'll need
to place light sensitive material at the
sharpest point of focus and open and
close the aperture with a shadow
mechanism and all of this is done in
absolute darkness we're using
photographic paper which is embedded
with light sensitive crystals to reveal
our captured image we need to dip our
photo paper into a chemical called
developer that starts the development
process causing the exposed crystals to
get darker than the unexposed ones we
then rinse the developer off in a stop
bar that stops the image from developing
further after that we dip it in fixer
which saves the developed image from
light how do you make the images less
creepy simple grab your negative and a
clean unexposed sheet of photographic
paper wet them pasting them together
push out any bubbles shine a light from
about 80 centimeters above for about
seven seconds then develop wash fix wash
and dry done a beautiful positive wet
print for you to show your friends and
family easy
now to test out this gigantic camera on
wheels this is martha she's new to joe
films you're going to be our model to
frame up a portrait just stand still for
the taste i'm just going to frame around
here
[Music]
obtain chimpanzee 11 chimpanzee
that was a big failure i had the lens
open for way too long i'm gonna do
another exposure test
okay i think that was around 20 seconds
a lot more detail here this is good
okay that's a good test but this is on a
very micro scale in comparison to what
we're doing tomorrow which is pretty
much
timesing this image by 21. it's a little
bit different but feeling good and then
bravo and i drove around cape town to
find the perfect location to get the
best angle of table mountain you don't
get the full view from here
looks like a better location i'm still
not sold 100.
[Music]
okay we've got the perfect location but
our camera's skewed so we're going to
need to somehow bring it level remember
that what we shoot goes onto the paper
there is a zero photoshop we have to
make sure everything is
perfect this is our tripod luckily i've
got these wooden ramps which i'm going
to try use now and then we're going to
place them down and try and get a
leveled image hopefully that doesn't
fall over okay brew you
can is when i feel like a filmmaker and
she starts getting dangerous
imagine it was just hard to frame up
your shot every time i'll tell you why
there'll be way less photographers
[Music]
that's good i'm just gonna have to get
up there
i'm ready to go i had to take everything
off besides my boxer shorts because the
temperature was 55 degrees celsius which
is 131 fahrenheit this will be the
biggest image i've ever taken there's so
much that that's gonna go into getting
this right
[ __ ] it went onto the image
it goes i'm gonna do this nine times and
i'm ready
if you can see how sweaty i am it's
insane
i wonder what the temperature is in here
is like a complete mind
game bruh
losing control
84
36
7
[ __ ] moving so slow in here pretty
wrong
sounds like these in my life i realize
how one doesn't appreciate the outdoors
one minute
all kinds of mind games here how
important is this picture
i found a tiny piece of fan yeah in the
battery
this is the last the final
40 seconds so we have to be in this
truck
that's it
hardest part done
wait for them to dry i go back to the
studio i'm going to turn them from
negatives to positives that was tough
that was real tough
[Music]
this video was brought to you by
discovery plus which is the home of
truly great filmmaking where putting in
the extra effort to getting that one
shot is what it's all about one of my
favorite documentaries on discovery plus
right now is lily tockles the world who
you probably know as havesh5 so go check
that out as well as the first four
episodes of the brew show are now live
on discovery plus so you can watch them
there before they go live on my youtube
channel and if you sign up now you get a
14 day discovery plus promotion by using
the promo code danmace this offer is
valid till the 25th of june 2022. so
yeah click on the link in my description
now to redeem your promotion back to the
video
in here i've got the same system
except we are inverting what we did the
negative
turn it into a positive into red mode
it's important to get up every bubble
that is a six and a half second exposure
this is my favorite process watching
this image come out wow
i just can't believe that these images
were taken from inside a truck
yes that is insane look let's see how
you can read mask there this is like the
most detailed i've ever seen on an image
by miles
there we have our first row
[Music]
top is 2 am right now been taking one
picture for like 17 hours
what's incredible about this is we've
got the negatives forever i could do
this again over and over and over which
is a beautiful thing
we are done
ta-da now
last step
now to put this puzzle piece together
[Music]
what this process has taught me is it's
not about the picture you take but
rather about the story behind the
picture and this picture tells one hell
of a story i just love all the
imperfections in this image it took a
total of 80 hours to get this one
picture just look at all the detail here
i am honored to have this picture on my
wall
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
week's video and other than that don't
forget you're also brew and i'll see you
soon
[Music]
you